Hello everyone. This is a lecture recording for chapter 4. In chapter 3, we saw the governing equations written in integral form, where we used the Reynolds transport theorem.
In chapter 4, we are going to derive the same governing equations for fluid motion, that are Navier-Stokes equations, but this time we are going to use the differential relations.
so our governing our fluid model will be infinitesimally small fluid elements fixed in the space so through the dx or dy or dz we can think about only the differential changes in our state to variable that can be the pressure or density
velocity, or even for the mass, right? Mass or momentum and energy. So throughout chapter four, first I'm going to talk about the total derivative and then I'm going to talk about the three important governing equations.
one is the conservation of the mass second one is the conservation of the linear momentum equation and the third one is the conservation of the energy equation then you may wonder the governing equations for all kinds of fluid motions are the same like observing those three governing equations but then your solutions all different for example velocity around
your car or velocity air, air velocity or air pressure around aircraft are all different, right? So what makes those kind of differences? There are the boundary conditions. So even though your governing equations are the same for all fluid motions, the boundary condition can be different for an individual problem. That's why you have the unique solution for specific problems, okay? [Review note: Boundary and initial conditions distinguish problems; they do not by themselves guarantee a unique solution for every nonlinear flow.]
So in today's recording, I'm going to talk about the same governing equations but utilizing a differential infinitesimally small fluid model
And then next video, I'm going to talk about some other important topics like stream function, vorticity, irrotationality, and viscous flows in a cylindrical pipe
So today's lecture I'm going to talk about the definition of the total derivative and then differential form of the mass conservation, momentum conservation and energy conservation
So let's think about acceleration, acceleration field of a fluid. Why acceleration is important?
because whenever we have the mass and acceleration we can there is a force right so we are going to think about velocity first velocity field is a function of time t and space x comma y comma z so your velocity is a vector and that is a function of space and time and it has a component of the u velocity in
in x direction, V velocity in y direction, and W velocity in k directions, right? So I, I, J, K, those are the unit vector in each orthogonal directions, right? But this vector U, B, W, they are also a function of space and time as well.
then acceleration field of the fluid is simply we have to think about the total time derivative of the velocity vector.
so since your fluid particle is moving so the derivative where V is a function of T, X, Y, Z, T then your UVW is also a function of X, Y, Z, T
So individual velocity components should also be differentiated by the total derivative.
So in the next slide, I'm going to define the total derivative.
So let's apply the chain rule to obtain each scalar time derivative.
For the du dt, partial u partial t plus partial u partial x multiplied by dx dt,
partial u partial y multiplied by the dy dt plus du dz dz dt and here du dx du is nothing but velocity u and dy dt is nothing but a velocity of v and dz dt is nothing but your velocity of the w so then du dt becomes here and this is u du dx v dvu dy
by w, d, u, d, z. So that we define as a total derivative of the velocity. And there is, by definition, there is acceleration. So acceleration is the total derivative of the velocity. So here I use a small d, but we often use that as a capital. d, v, d, t.
So if you think about a solid that are stationary in space, then your total derivative is the same as the partial derivative, right?
But if something is moving, like if your velocity is changing over space and time, then we should think about the total derivative that can be decomposed into the local time derivative, local acceleration, which means that your velocity is fixed. [Review note: The following sentence clarifies that the observation location, not the velocity value, is fixed.]
you are looking into a fixed space and you are looking into the velocity changes at that fixed location that is the local acceleration or the second one is the convective acceleration so here it is the time rate of change due to the motion so your velocity is changing from here to here right so at the given fixed
So at given time, your velocity here and your velocity here is different, then you have to consider the convective derivative, that is, inner product, that is multiplied into U, V, W
u db dx plus v db dy and w db dx [Review note: Symbol recognition is uncertain. The slide states u(partial V/partial x) + v(partial V/partial y) + w(partial V/partial z).]
in vector form we can write this convective derivative as v inner product of the gradient
so partial t plus v inner product of gradient and v
that is the definition of the total derivative
and here gradient is a differentiation vector in vector form.
So partial partial x comma partial partial y comma partial partial z.
So that is partial partial x comma partial partial y comma partial partial z.
So the total derivative operator, if I rewrite the total derivative operator DDT or capital D or capital DT, then there is the summation of the local derivative where space is fixed and we are looking only into the temporal variation and then convective derivative,
there is the dx plus b, d, dy plus w, d, dz. So there is the convective derivative and there is the time derivative due to the convection, due to the motion, due to your movement from place A to place Z.
So this slide shows acceleration but since a total derivative can be applied to velocity here but then you can apply that to a mass flow or momentum flow or energy flux flux per unit area flow per unit area
okay so if you remember in chapter 3 in chapter 3 I was looking into some fixed control volume right
control fixed control volume of a finite volume fixed a space and then I was introducing
in Reynolds transport theorem, Reynolds transport theorem, where your ddt is your time rate of change of something is nothing but your ddt control volume, right, bdb and then so that is the time rate of change of some property b inside your control volume.
control volume, they should be the same as flux moving in and out of your control surface, right? So that is the Reynolds transport theorem and here you will not see A, it should be C, C, S, it should be C, S and B, V, dot, N, D, A equals zero. So that was the Reynolds transport theory, right? [Review note: The zero right-hand side applies to the mass-conservation specialization, not to every transported extensive property.]
So, but this chapter 4, so these are the integral relations, right? We are looking into the control volume, volume integral and also the surface integral. But in chapter 4, we are looking into this type of, this is infinitesimally small, infinitesimally, infinitesimally small element, element that is fixed.
that is fixed in space. So in chapter 4, in chapter 3, our control volume is fixed in space but it has a finite volume. But in chapter 4, to utilize the differential relations, we are looking into a very tiny
a tiny element that is infinitesimally small element but it is fixed in space so if you think about the control volume this side right can be your volume is the same so they can be dv integral of the cv dv can be dx dy dz
okay so we can approximate that so the left side is always you know B so there will be partial so in chapter 3 we had that term but in chapter 4 that part will be changing into B partial partial T DX DY DG so this term will always turn into that one
and then right-hand side, this is the flux coming in and out of the surface, right? So for the disturb, we'll be looking into the three phases, x-face, y-face, and z-face, and in an x-face, rho-yu, so this is rho-yu is a mass flux, right? Mass flux, so mass flux multiplied by the area
there will be mass flow rate so something coming in and something coming out but this mass flux in the left phase and in right phase this mass flux has some variation but how much of the variation we are utilizing the Taylor series expansion up to the first order so we are looking into the Taylor series expansion about
the rho u but up to the first gradient the first derivative so this is the your mass flow coming mass flow meaning we multiply by the area mass flow coming out of your right surface okay so rho u dy dz plus rho u d rho u dx dx dy dz so that's the mass flow rate
coming out of the x-axis. And then you can do the same thing for the y. So this is the x-axis, right? That is normal to the x-axis. Y-axis is the top and bottom.
okay y faces are the top and bottom top and bottom are the y faces then front and back front and back are the front and back are the fluxes coming out in the z directions right so rho v rho w rho v rho w
and then small variation, linear variation. So this implies the linear variation over dx, dy, dz. So we are going to apply this approach throughout the chapter 4. In chapter 3 we had the control volume, time rate of change inside control volume and then flux
coming in and out of the control surface. But for the chapter 4, this control volume change will be directly written here. And then flux coming in and out can be taken into account in x-faces, y-faces, and z-faces with assumption of the linear increase or decrease in x-direction, y-direction, and z-direction by dx, dy, and dz.
so then our continuity equation so if we sum this up right so m dot out minus m dot in so if we consider the x directions only minus rho u dy dz plus m dot out rho u plus partial rho u partial x dx dy dz
then those two will be cancelled out and I will have that one only right so that is left so that is probably it has to be multiplied by the original dx dy dz and that term is here and then taking the mass flux in the y direction will be partial rho y dx dy dz
and this is a z direction, that's flux, and then this term d rho dt dx dy dz is in this term, and then if I cancel out dx dy dz, dx dy dz, then we have that, and that is the continuity equation in differential form, okay, Cartesian coordinates,
and there's a little polar coordinate you don't memorize it but you can always transform two coordinates from the Cartesian to polar coordinates so these are the relation and then this is a steady, steady meaning partial derivative to time can be zero and compressible meaning your rho is not constant
so rho can change with respect to x and y and z in space so in this case the first term time derivative term will be cancelled out and we have partial rho u partial x plus partial rho v partial y plus partial rho w partial z
equals zero. So that is the mass equation or we call it as a continuity equation. Continuity equation for steady and compressible flow for incompressible flow meaning density change is negligible. So d rho dt or
or rho is constant. We can consider rho is a constant. Then regardless of whether the flow is steady or unsteady, we can write it as a du dx plus db dy plus dz equals 0.
So that is the gradient of velocity is zero. So that is the famous continuity equation for incompressible flow. [Review note: The displayed expression is divergence, div V = 0, not the full velocity gradient.]
So we will be utilizing this form a lot.
and the continuity equation is always important and must always be satisfied for a rational analysis of a flow pattern.
So mass is not created or destroyed. More importantly mass flow rate is the same everywhere. [Review note: Equal mass flow rates require a steady streamtube or a control volume with no mass accumulation and matching ports; this is not a general unsteady statement.]
okay so here just for your reference mass flow rate flow rate is rho u a then mass flux is per unit area so rho v then what about the volume flow rate volume flow rate we have to divide by the density so that is the v and a okay so that is the volume flow rate
rate. Then let's take some example to utilize the mass equation, continuity equation. So incompressible velocity field is given by incompressible meaning your rho is constant. So anything differentiate density should be zero. So u is given as a function of x and y and v unknown and w is a constant where a and b are constant.
what must the form of the velocity be? So for incompressible flow, the continuity equation applies partial u, partial x. So what is this? Partial u, partial x plus partial v, partial y plus partial w, partial z equals 0.
so u is a times x squared plus y squared so insert that one plug that one into u and we don't know the v and w is a constant so they will go to zero so dv dy will be 2ax and we want to calculate v so we want to integrate that with respect to y [Review note: The ASR loses a possible minus sign. The slide and continuity require partial v/partial y = -2ax; do not quote the ASR sign as a confirmed spoken value.]
but that has to be integrating partially because at this point we are taking x as a constant. So velocity b is a 2axy plus constant but there can be a function of x or I didn't say this is a two-dimensional so g and also it could also be a time of [Review note: Using the displayed continuity equation gives v = -2axy + f(x,z,t). This is an editorial algebra check, not reconstructed speech.]
team right so this is the only possible form for V that satisfies the continuity equation okay another example that can be important for the mass conservation so this is the piston and piston compresses a gas in a cylinder at constant speed so you can consider density can change
inside your piston right so for the differential relations we don't have to worry about the control volume okay so in chapter 3 we always started with the control volume but in chapter 4 we don't need a control volume right so at one instant when piston is at L0.15 meter away from the closed end of the cylinder [Review note: A differential analysis still uses an infinitesimal control volume in the derivation; no new finite control volume is selected for each example.]
and then gas density is 18 and then gas velocity varies from the V at the piston to zero at the V equal zero and here the velocity is a V okay so here V you can say U
so that is the sorry at the this location your u was the at this end when the piston moves from here to here here u is the zero right so find an expression for the average gas density as a function of time rho of t and then the rate
a bit of change of gas density at this instant it's rho dot d rho dt okay so let's apply the continuity equation but this time this in 1D and this is a compressible right this is a compressible so you have to bring up the compressible
form of the mass equation. In one dimensional, in one dimensional, so there will be partial rho partial t plus partial rho u partial x equals 0 or partial partial rho partial t equals minus partial rho u partial x equals
by part of rule we have minus rho partial u partial x minus u partial rho partial x so here rho changes over time but then at a given time density here density here is the same it means that density doesn't vary over x right so partial rho
partial x equals 0, then u velocity in terms of the x, right, when x equals 0, it has to be v, when x equals l, it has the l, it has the u equals 0.
So it changes linearly. So V minus V over LX. So here L changes and L is a function of T. So let's look into it. L is L0 at time T equals 0 but it changes at the velocity of V.
and not minus bt. So here, so this one partial rho partial t is partial rho partial x equal to 0. So we have only that one. Partial rho partial t is minus rho partial u partial x. And then if you differentiate u with respect to x, then we will have
right this one right minus rho minus VL. L is L0 minus VT right so we have that one have that and we separate the variables and if we integrate so here the rho DT and this one so here separate the variable of the
rho and t, although rho is a function of t, but at this moment, let's separate those two and integrate, so d rho over rho, d rho over rho, right, so rho is moving to the here and t goes to here, then integrate, not over, so that dt doesn't go, right, so my expression is wrong,
but if I move the rho to the left hand side then right hand side is d only a function of the t so we can integrate the right hand side by dt while we integrate left hand side by d rho then what happens is that left hand side we have ln left hand side left hand side if we integrate 1 over 1 over rho
then there will be ln natural lock of the rho from rho0 to rho and that right hand side we will also we have to integrate with respect to t so we will also have the ln value right so we have the 3 minus 1 over v then ln
and L0 minus bt right so if we cancel out then we will have ln L0 minus bt inverse right so that has to be 0 and t so that can also be a simple then we will have
of this one. Rho over rho naught will be right hand side L naught over L naught minus bt. So you can do the simple calculation to get the right hand side here.
then our rho can be what? rho is a from here our from here rho now let's consider as a function of t rho t will be rho naught L naught 1 over L0 minus Vt right so that is our rho t
and then if we differentiate that, then 3 with respect to T, then what we will have is rho0, L0, this one, right?
So if we differentiate that with respect to T, then rho0, L0, and minus T, right?
okay I'm sorry minus so this is minus the exponent minus 1 so minus 1 L0 minus bt minus 2 and minus d okay so there will be the positive and we will have rho0 L0 B divided by the L0 minus bt square
okay at time t equals zero then we will have rho naught B over L naught so that is exactly what we are that is exactly the derivative of the 0 dt right so we have rho naught as an 18 B B as a 12
and L naught is 0.15 so we have the density time rate of change of the density is 1440 so here we got the expression of rho t and then we got the partial rho partial t in here so rho t as this form rho t has that one and then partial rho partial t is
is this one okay so let's move on to the momentum equation but this time a differential form right so differential equations of a linear momentum again the linear momentum for fixed control volume and 1d momentum flux by Reynolds transport theorem we have that one for the 1d case right so these are the
time rate of change of the momentum, rho, V inside the momentum flux inside your control volume and there is a momentum flux coming in and out of our control surface so this one so these are from the fixed control volume and then if we change that we want to change that into a differential form so we have the linear momentum changes in control volume
is, we can have that one, so ddt can be getting inside, partial partiality, rho v, and then volume is the same, the x, dy, dz, so here, this is a force, right, so we have to think about what types of the force do we have to worry in this case, we have to think about the body force and the surface force, right,
So this graph shows the surface force in six faces, so sigma x to the left x faces, and sigma yx in the bottom faces, and then sigma zx in the back faces
space. So we will look into it. So we change that one into this one. We change that one into this one. But what about this term? So we will consider the momentum flux terms in all six directions. So in x direction, so this rho uv, that's the momentum flux, right? So rho uv coming, right? So in here,
this one we have the rho uv and this one we have rho uv plus partial x rho uv dx okay so that is the momentum flux and then momentum flow can be if we multiply by the area dy dz right so multiply by dy dz
so if we take the direction and that has to be negative and that has to be positive right so that has to be cancelled out we have rho uv dx right we have that one right so here rho uv here right we have the rho uv we have the this one
partial rho uv, partial rho uv dx coming from, by taking into in and out in x direction, and this rho vv is from the, this one cancelled out, and we have partial partial y rho vv dy dx dx dx dx dx dx dx is left here, in g direction, that has cancelled out, and we have that left in here, right? [Review note: Repeated dx tokens are unreliable ASR of pointed-at notation. Each net face-pair contribution is a spatial derivative times dx dy dz.]
So this is the ma term. We haven't considered the force yet, but linear momentum equation is based on the F equals ma, right?
So you can consider we saw the ma term here. And then there is a jump from left-hand side to the right-hand side.
and then they we change it this form into the this one how do we do that is I will take the problem so this one partial rho v partial t can be rho partial v partial t plus one sec plus v partial
I just expand that one using the product rule and then I will also apply the product rule for three of them but this time rho u and v so v partial rho u partial x plus v from this term v partial rho v
v partial y plus from that term v partial rho w partial z right and then we have the another term rho u from here rho u partial v partial x plus from that term rho v partial v partial x right and then
and that term rho w partial w partial x and here if we group some terms so this one v d rho dt v d1 and d1 and d1 they can be written in terms of the v
there will be partial rho partial t plus partial rho u partial x plus partial rho v partial y plus partial rho w partial z right then what's left over there one there one there one there one right so here
the common factor is a rho so if I take the rho out then if I take the rho out then what's left is db dt plus this one will be u
u partial v partial x plus v partial e why did i write it here i will just put it i will write it
so plus plus here if I take the row out then I will have partial V partial T plus from here from this one right so I have U partial V partial X plus this one
v partial v partial y plus w partial v partial z right so if I look into this term that one what is that this one there is the continuity equation for the compressible flow right so that should go to zero by continuity and then what about that one
that one is exactly the total derivative of the velocity dv dt right so we have rho here dv dt here and then dx dy dz left so the ma term when from the f equal ma ma term can be nothing but rho capital dv dt plus dx dy dz [Review note: The final factor is multiplication by dx dy dz, not addition of a volume to an acceleration.]
so we saw that one and then next slide we are looking into the force term so the net force the net forces on the control volume must be of the differential size and proportional to the elemental volume and these forces include the body force and surface force so
so gravitational force can be rho g dx dy dz so this is the gravity force and then normal force minus gradient p where does it come from this can also be pressure is always pointing inward right so here p and here p plus partial p partial x
x dx and then to be a pressure force dy dz and if you multiply dy dz then that that is cancelled out because of the different direction right and then we have dead left so that is dead coming from the gradient p and why do you have a minus because right hand side this should be a positive sign for the force force right
so we have the minus p and then what about the viscous work viscous work is next slide we are looking into the viscous stress viscous stress is we use the Einstein notation so this viscous stress is a tensor and i varies from one two three
and J varies from 1, 2, 3. So here tau xx meaning tau 1, 1. So tau xx, tau yz, tau gx. So these are the viscous stress. And then if I and J are the same, then viscous stress is classified as a normal viscous stress.
or shear, viscous stress. So whether this is a normal or shear, viscous stress is coming from the velocity gradient. So the most practical example can be the boundary layer.
so let's assume that this is a solid surface and then air is moving this direction as a u free stream then here your particle cannot move at the u infinity particle should be stick to the surface surface v wall is a zero right which means that your u at the wall should be zero
so your velocity profile will be zero at the bottom and it will gradually recovering to the u infinities outside is u infinity everywhere right so this one this one this area where you have the velocity gradient we say that is the boundary layer flow boundary layer flow
and whenever you have a surface which has the non-zero roughness, non-zero roughness, then you will have the friction force and that always retard the velocity of your particle. [Review note: A viscous boundary layer does not require a geometrically rough wall; a smooth no-slip wall also has one.]
So here, so this is a very good example. So this is the x direction and then you have the variation in y, right?
So if you think about your velocity here and here, there is a change in the velocity which means that you will have the viscous shear stress in between those space.
So tau xx is tau yx, tau zx, and then this notation, the first notation i represents, this is the index of the face that is acting upon, and then j is the direction of the force on the surface
so go to the next slide so here so sigma xx so this is a the sigma ij is the just a stress stress can include also the hydrostatic pressure as well so and tau is the viscous stress so stress surface stress is the pressure and
normal viscous stress on the x, so this is x-faces, this is also x-faces, okay, so that is the x-faces, surface, and then y, normal to the y-axis, so this one is the y-face, okay, so this is the y-face,
so y-face and then top and front and back these are the normal to the z-axis right so these are the z-face okay so here so notation here the first index represents sigma ij so sigma ij where i stressed in j-direction
on a face normal to the i-axis. So i means x surface, x-face, and in acting, so sigma x is acting on this surface, this x-face, this x-face, but there are three components.
sigma xx is moving in this direction and that is due to the u gradient in u in the direction of the x
then we have the sigma xy, sigma xy meaning sigma xy meaning this is equivalent to the tau xy
equivalent to the tau x, y, tau x, y and this tau x, y meaning this viscous shear stress is acting on x-faces but in the y direction so this direction that is the sigma x, y and there is the same as the tau that is only shear term and this one also this one is the sigma x, z
say sigma xz, that is the same as the tau xz, so it is acting on the x-faces, but in the z direction, so this is a shear, shear, shear, this is normal stress, normal viscous stress, right, and then this viscous stress is, viscous stress tau ij, that is proportional to the element strain rate, this one, strain rate, we saw it from the solid mechanics, right,
so strain rate and also the coefficient of the viscosity mu and we are sigma ij stress, tau ij viscous stress or epsilon ij strain rate those are the nine component tensor okay so vector you have to be careful between vector and tensor
so vector denotes only vector represents only the direction okay tensor is on which phase it is a directing so it has a normal and shear term as well and then for an incompressible flow tau xy its name is tau yx this is isotropic tau xz is tau zx and tau yz is tau zy [Review note: For an ordinary nonpolar continuum, stress symmetry follows from angular momentum balance, not incompressibility alone.]
and then these are the mu multiple, mu is the dynamic viscosity, mu is a dynamic viscosity, dynamic viscosity, and then mu multiplied by the average of the two shear, the velocity gradient in different directions, du dy, db dx, okay, this one is the dw dx and du dz, stuff like that. [Review note: The displayed shear stress is mu times the SUM of the two velocity gradients, equivalently twice mu times the strain-rate tensor component.]
so from here so these are the stress right so to get so we saw how I got the minus del p and how to get this one one sec so for that one you can also do the same thing so here for the pressure I was taking p dy dz and
and this one right you can do the same thing for the shear stress as well so if you see the sigma xy here so tau i tau xy so if you have the tau xy tau xx or tau xx if you have the tau xx then you have the tau xx
xx here and then this one you have the tau xx plus linear variation partial tau xx partial x dx right so you then you will multiply the area dy dz right so this is the right so that's how you get here this component and this I
instead of the tau I just represent tau in terms of the velocity term so these are the incompressible momentum equation so these are the mass equations right so these are the momentum equation and some people say
okay Navier-Stokes equation just to refer to momentum equation but more generally these days when we say Navier-Stokes equation meaning it refers to the mass equation one mass equation three momentum equation and one energy equation all together so five equations okay but anyways these are the momentum equation and left hand side is the mass multiplied by
by the acceleration but acceleration is in the total derivative form because it can be moving the right hand side is this is the force term gravity force this one is the pressure force and these are the viscous forces okay so these are the in PDE form and this is the second order right second order and this is nonlinear because unknowns are multiplied into the another unknown so this is a nonlinear
non-linear PDE and this is a coupled because W is moving shown here but you have the math equations right so we saw what was it partial rho partial t plus partial rho u partial x plus partial rho v partial y plus partial
Rho w partial z equals zero right so w u v can appear in the mass equations as well okay so these are the couples and these are the second order PDE so this is exactly why the calculation of the Navier-Stokes equation is still impossible [Review note: This is not a claim adopted by the notes: special exact solutions and numerical solutions exist; the next two examples derive special exact solutions.]
okay so let's take some examples to apply the linear momentum equation so this is a Couette flow and then the next example is the Poiseuille flow those are very famous flows in a viscous flow so first Couette flow consider this is a pipe but this is a
2D incompressible viscous flow between parallel plates a distance to each apart we assume that the plates are very wide and long so the flow is essentially axial and u is not zero but v velocity w velocity is zero and the bottom plate is fixed but that upper plate is moving at the velocity of the v so here we want to calculate
I will calculate the velocity distribution between plates. I will calculate the U of Y here. And so here I draw this line. So U0 at the bottom and then U gradually increasing linearly and at the top by slip condition. If this is moving, this also has to be moving. We call it as a no slip condition.
no slip condition. What we mean by that is if the wall velocity is fixed then U0 has to be zero but if the wall is moving then your gas velocity at contact should also be V. So that is the no slip condition.
So shear driven flow, shear driven flow meaning you have induced velocity and then you have the velocity gradient in the y. So there are going to be some shear stresses. So this is shear driven.
from the continuity equation this is incompressible so we will disregard density rho so we have that one gradient v is a zero and then further v equals zero w equals zero so we have du dy dx partial u partial x equals zero integrated with respect to and then we saw u is a function of ui only [Review note: The displayed condition is divergence V = 0. Under the stated steady, two-dimensional assumptions, u = u(y).]
and then apply the Navier-Stokes equation. So here, fully developed meaning, you typically use that term, fully developed in the pipe flow. Now pipe flow, when you say fully developed meaning, in whether that x location, at this location, at that location, your velocity profile is exactly the same.
So there is no variation in x here as well. Your velocity profile is exactly here. So let's bring up the momentum equation for 2D flow in the x direction then du dx is 0, phi is 0 and dp dx is 0. So there is no pressure variation.
so let's say that this is one state and this is a two state there is no variation in the pressure
so dp dx equals zero and since du dx equals zero second derivative of the u with respect to x is zero
and then this is not zeros right so you only have that tablet second derivative of the u with respect
so if we integrate twice then we have the line with the two unknown to c1 and c2 so we will apply the boundary condition at the upper and lower plates so no slip condition no slip condition meaning your V wall should be wall velocity should be the same as the V gas at the wall
so if the wall is fixed here then this is a 1 minus h right since the wall doesn't move wall balance is a zero so your u is a zero at the top at y equal h your wall is moving at the b velocity then the gas right the contact should also have to move at the velocity of b so if we
we integrate that U equal V right so from here no no not integration so we are adding that one and that one to calculate c1 and c2 so your velocity profile is a linear and we have that if you insert y equals minus h your u will be zero if you plug y equals h your u will become a V
so that is the Couette flow and then this is the Poiseuille flow so here this is also a pipe but this time your top wall and bottom wall is also fixed so
so consider 2D incompressible viscous flow between two parallel plates a distance 2h apart so both plates are fixed which means that so this is a fix your wall velocity is zero at the bottom and top so the gas at the contact should also velocity should be zero but then there is a pressure variance in the x direction so probably
P here is a high and P here is a low so there is a pressure gradient so your flow your fluid has to flow so U is not zero but then you're so because of that motion there will be oh gas felt like you know the fluid velocity so your U is not zero but V and W is a zero here
So neglect the gravity effect. Determine the velocity distribution between the plates. So we want to calculate U of Y. So this is a pressure driven flow. So anyways, let's apply the continuity equation.
So you may notice that I never took a control volume in chapter 4 because our flow model is infinitesimally small. So this is our continuity equation for the incompressible flow. I said that is the incompressible, right? So rho is dropped. And here we don't have any v equals 0, w equals 0.
So these two terms will be cancelled out. We have only t u dx equals 0. So u is u only. Then let's bring up the Navier-Stokes equation for 2D flow in the x-direction. And this time this is also fully developed.
fully developed meaning your velocity u of y will be same in all x direction so probably at this location your velocity will be this much right and further down you have the same u max at the center that is a fully developed which means that du dx will be zero du dx will be zero and we don't have any v velocity
and since du dx is 0 second derivative of u with x equals 0 so we have a non-zero pressure gradient and then second non-zero second gradient of the u with respect to y so we have that one right so here so is a dp dx a constant but at least if you can consider a constant in terms of y right so this is not a constant
function of not a function of y and a function of y and this is we say this is a fully developed meaning pressure gradient should be the same everywhere that so that you know your u u y doesn't change in x so but then it doesn't have to be constant okay if we don't consider if we don't consider the fully developed assumption of the fully developed then dp dx can also be a function of x as well [Review note: For the fully developed, steady, constant-viscosity parallel-plate model here, dp/dx is constant. Dropping fully developed flow also removes the basis for the same u(y) solution.]
but definitely not a function of y so you know if we integrate y this one twice then we have quadratic u is a quadratic form so with the two constants here so let's apply boundary condition at the bottom plates and then top plates with a no slip condition
so at y equals h u equals 0 and y equals minus h u equals 0 right so you can get c1 and c2 with that value you can calculate the velocity distribution at maximum velocity happens at y equals 0 so that is this one and you get this is the parabola shape okay so this is the quadratic parabolic shape defined by
okay this equation okay finally we are moving into the equation of energy so the same thing energy equation is based on the first law of the thermodynamics right so heat edit work done on the system if we take example of the minus then there is the same as the and also the
this shaft work and viscous work right then that has to be same as the rate of change of the energy right but by the Reynolds transport theorem that rate of change of the energy inside the control volume and then you think about the energy flux coming in and out
So here, E plus P over rho, rho, B and D A. So we already derived this from the chapter 3. So I just write it here. And shaft work this time is a zero because there's no infinitesimally small shaft work. But viscous work is not zero, although small, right?
okay so so what I mean right so here energy flux right so by analogy with the linear momentum equation which means that so this one will go to zero left-hand side q dot minus w dot v and then right-hand side pressure work is uh uh uh pressure work is included here viscous work is separated here so uh
E plus p over rho that we define as a zeta then from energy transfer theorem okay so we can have like in the momentum equation we can have the energy flux coming in and coming out so here E rho u zeta
dy dz this is energy flow and that is the rho u j plus partial rho u j dx partial x dx multiplied by the dy dz right so if we so this is a coming
coming in and this is a coming out right energy direct out minus in so that will be cancelled out we have the this one left so that is here right likewise in the y direction y direction this is x direction and this is y direction and this is z direction if you do the same thing in x y z direction then we have that term and that left right so how can you get
use energy flux terms on six surfaces that I just shown in one direction and then expand the last three terms here by product rule and use the continuity equation checked page 13 of slice 13 of slice then you will see exactly how I
okay got this one so uh then right hand side can be written total derivative in terms of that one okay let's say that as an equation one then this term so right hand side can be use this one and then left hand side first let's look into the heat flux term heat flow term so i will use the Fourier's law
so we are considering only the conduction here for the heat term we have the radiation, conduction and convection but since this is such a small small element so we don't consider radiation much we don't consider we neglect the radiation we also we don't have any radiation and then we consider we disregard only the convection so we consider only [Review note: Only conductive heat flux is modeled here. Advective energy transport remains in the material derivative and is not discarded.]
need the conduction here. So Fourier's law, heat transfer per unit area is a proportional to the grain of the temperature. So this is the Fourier's law, right? So Qx is minus K dt dx, where K is the thermal conductivity that is specific to the material, right?
okay so qx, qy, qi, qz and then I use the same notation for the heat flux so heat flow per unit area is the heat flux so heat flux in the x direction is this one y direction qx and then linear variation right
okay so if we consider heat flux into the control volume into the control volume then there will be qx minus qx plus partial qx partial x dx right multiply by the dy dz and those will be cancelled out
so we have this one minus dqx dx and then in the y direction we have that one, z direction we have that one, right?
And here qx, qy, qz can be written in terms of the Fourier law, then q dot can be gradient of the k gradient t dx dy dz, so that's the total p rate. [Review note: The operator is divergence of k grad T, a scalar heat-input rate per volume, not a vector gradient.]
and what about the viscous work, viscous work here we have to think about the viscous work per unit area per unit area as well so if we think about the surface at the top and bottom so here and here right so here and that one and then if we right so this this element
and then if you consider tau yx at the top and then tau yx at the bottom okay and then u is your top is going that way and u bottom is going this way then viscous work per area will be bottom
minus tau yx bottom multiplied by the ub plus that can be utop and this one's the multiplication of the dojo two can be written in terms of the Taylor series expansion.
so tau x, y, b, u, b plus partial partial x, tau x, y, b, u, b right sorry for the pair right there this is not dx this should be the dy right because y top and bottom we have the elemental changes in the y not x
is a partial y, partial x, y, b multiplied by the u, b and dy. And so this will be canceled out. And if we multiply dx, dz, so that if we do the same thing for the tau gx and tau to the same,
do the same for tau xx and tau gx by gx then we have that term, that term and that term okay so in the y direction we have that one, that one and that one w we have that, that, that
so that is the net viscous work throughout the six faces so if we rewrite that into a vector form we have that and then we can further expand this gradient term with the dissipation and then this is a phi is the viscous dissipation function
so what we are doing we are deriving the energy equation here so this is this equation but this time we are looking into a infinitesimally small element so we are deriving the equation of energy in differential form okay so this is a viscous work we saw the heat edit work done by
by the viscous force and then pressure force is included in here right included in the here left hand side so all right and then this let's look into this dissipation term since all terms are quadratic so this one there one there one there one there one there one there one all quadratic so viscous dissipation is always a positive it means that a viscous flow always tends to [Review note: The displayed sum of squares gives Phi >= 0; Phi can be zero when the strain-rate tensor vanishes.]
to lose its available energy due to the dissipation. So that is accordance with the second law of the thermodynamics which means that entropy is always increasing in a spontaneous process.
so these are the I didn't write it in terms of the you know Cartesian form this is the vector form so plug equation 2 and 3 equation 3 is a viscous work and equation 2 is the energy the heat flow then this is the energy equation then we have this one okay so this is the energy equation and then
so far, sorry guys, so far we have looked into previously we saw, previously we derived, mass equation, mass conservation equation we call it as a continuity equation, mass equation, and then momentum equation, some people say that as a Navier-Stokes equation,
or we just derive the energy equations right energy energy equation and this is one equation there are three equation and these are the one equation so generally all together we say that is a Navier-Stokes equation okay so our variables are pressure we want to keep with the pressure everywhere
we want to calculate velocity, we want to calculate the density, if density changes or the temperature, if the heat is added or work is done there will be changes in the temperature so those are our unknowns and then the governing equation those can be found if we can solve the Navier-Stokes equation but like I said Navier-Stokes equation is one of the seven millennia equations there is no exact solution [Review note: The sweeping no-exact-solution statement is not used as a mathematical result; the lecture itself derives Couette and Poiseuille exact solutions.]
Although a couple of weeks ago, people say about 10,000 AI agents, right? There was the collaboration among Claude and ChatGPT and Gemini, I believe. So they say, they declared that using 10,000 AI agents, they were able to solve the Navier-Stokes equation. [Review note: This is an unverified anecdote by the lecturer, not a source establishing a mathematical breakthrough; it is excluded from the study-note claims.]
but then they didn't get an exact solution but they just say you know the exist they say okay there will be a solution of the Navier-Stokes equation under certain assumptions. I believe that's what they have found so far. [Review note: The preceding anecdote is not independently established here.]
So these are the all-coupled and second-order PDE and these are the highly non-linear
Okay guys, that's all for the governing equations in fluid mechanics using differential relations
conditions. And then in the next video, I'm going to talk about the boundary condition and also the stream function, vorticity and irrotationality. Thank you guys.